this football Garb is unique to the
first World Cup in the Middle East
the male headdress and the thobe an
ankle length white robe worn primarily
by Arab men in the Gulf now feature team
jerseys and country flags
it's surprisingly cool that was the
first thing that I thought when I put
this on is I was going to you know start
sweating it was hot but it's uh it's
keeping the breeze going so it's nice
the more than century-old sukwakif has
become a runway for football fashion
when I go to back to San Diego that's
where I'm from I'm going to wear this
going um for every Mexican match that
goes on there
you might start a trend exactly this is
the only place on the planet where you
can buy a ghatra
or a phobe you see there's a jersey here
with a flag on the bottom the hatra
costs about twenty dollars the phobes
about 30.
in one of the unexpected cultural
exchanges taking place Cuttery men are
stopping to give fans a fashion primer
showing their favorite take on how to
wear the each man has his preference
yeah
we are really very happy and we are
proud that this people is wearing the
sour traditional dress even there is not
wearing exactly like us we are wearing
but really it is uh we are we are so so
happy
well locals just stop lean in make the
adjustment with a smile and continue on
their way it's a prime example of the
cuttery's understated hospitality
clearly it's also a source of Pride that
the world is celebrating country attire
and learning just how cool and
comfortable it is especially in the
desert heat Natasha name Al Jazeera Doha